Facebook reels right now is out of
control Facebook text only posts
organically on your fan page out of
control everybody's abandoned Facebook
fan pages there's unlimited customers
there and YouTube shorts is really great
because if you title them based on
search because YouTube's the second
biggest search engine in the world it
becomes much more longevity than let's
say a tick tock so YouTube shorts for
this room is incredibly incredibly
important equally to tick tock and the
other things the reason I'm pushing Tick
Tock so much is I just want everybody to
go into that swimming pool because I
agree with you they'll continue to out
innovate everybody else and then I just
want them to have that base but I do
think for a lot of people the YouTube
shorts executions that's a very similar
exactly what they do on Tick Tock will
end up becoming even more effective for
their business and definitely the long
tail because of the search capabilities